[Applause]
[Music]
Venezuela is like Game of Thrones we all
want to know how it's going to end but
at the same time we all know that we're
going to be disappointed with the ending
and this is exactly what we're going to
be talking about today many of you have
the same question in mind how can the
Venezuelan crisis end
[Music]
we're talking about one of the biggest
financial and humanitarian catastrophes
in modern history in just 10 years
they've gone from exporting oil to
exporting refugees but you already knew
this we've got several videos here on
visual politic that cover this very
issue of course Venezuela is not the
only country that has gone completely
bankrupt you also have the example of
Nicaragua during the 1980s Nicaragua
suffered from hyperinflation scarcity of
resources and extreme poverty as well
but in that case there was a clear
alternative to power and it was easy to
figure out what could happen next
[Music]
Venezuela instead is a big-time mystery
think about it the Venezuelan president
Nicolas Maduro is up against the wall as
we said in this video he even came up
with his own cryptocurrency for petrol
as a desperate attempt to get some
foreign currency if things keep going
this way he won't even have the money to
pay the arne that keeps him in power but
this is not the worst problem the real
mystery of our Venezuela is who is the
alternative is there really somebody who
can substitute maduras rule somebody
with enough political capital to change
things in this country and it's hard to
say so far
[Music]
so in summary it is almost impossible to
understand the current political
situation in Venezuela and this is why
we wanted to talk to one of the world's
largest experts in political transitions
and you might wonder well who are we
talking about here historian from a
think-tank and economists maybe well
we've got someone way better if I'm
Philip was the finance minister of the
Czech Republic during the first years
after the fall of communism
[Music]
here's one of the architects of the
Czech Republic as it exists today but
this is not the end of the story after
having a remarkable political career he
started a business in South America this
means he knows this region as well as
the palm of his hand and with that said
let me introduce you to him hello to all
the visual politic subscribers all right
Simon is just impossible to imagine what
could actually happen in Venezuela
but today we are going to draw three
different potential scenarios based on
the recent history so today's question
is what can happen in Venezuela what
potential scenarios can we foresee in
this country we're going to answer these
questions but before we do let's take a
look back at the history
[Music]
check way out remember this name mud
Slav hovel few people have had more
influence on the history of a country
than him just feel really dirty last
read are you miserably at junior
everybody's basically the Czech Republic
we know today the Czech Republic whereby
happen to live is what it is thanks to
fat Slav harvelle and believe me this is
a big success story for a democratic
transition while other countries like
Russia or Ukraine are still poor and
unequal societies the Czech Republic is
prosperous modern and surprisingly
egalitarian they have low unemployment a
thriving middle class and the political
rights of any other European country but
well how did they get here
[Music]
until the year 1989 checks lift and a
Moscow controlled government under the
dictatorship of Gustav Vasa things like
going abroad on vacation
we're forbidden or very difficult if you
wanted to rent a house or flat you will
need a special permit it will take years
to go the countries like Poland despite
having a communist regime they were a
little bit more open in fact many checks
even which tried to cross the Polish
border so they could buy books it were
forbidden in Czechoslovakia it's time
nonetheless everything changed at the
end of the 1980s even though we never
had the hyperinflation to heaven than as
well today we suffer scarcity did you
want to buy a car you had to have paid
four years and to the state-owned
factory would send your basic things
like bananas better luxury that was
impossible to find in most of the shops
maybe with the exception of Christmas
the same happened with most of the
fruits and vegetable means at many
different other products
add to this the fact that the Soviet
Union couldn't send money to their
allies anymore so with no foreign
support and a bankrupt economy it's not
all to have all kinds of protests of
course at first police suppress the
protests against hosaka rule of course
on the first stage Boris repressed the
protest against tourists are true but
what happens when all of a sudden you
have more than 250,000 people on the
streets of Prague we wouldn't be crazy
to start shooting court of million
unlike Nicolas Maduro the
Czechoslovakian government understood
that the best thing they could do was
step down from power in a peaceful
fashion thanks to this good stuff who
sac got his golden retirement and the
Czech Revolution was known as The Velvet
Revolution because no blood was spilled
nonetheless as I said at the beginning
the key to this process was the
prominent figure of vaselov Havel he was
a famous writer back then and he managed
to capitalize on all of the political
unrest
truth and love will overcome lies and
hatred
Vaslav hava in fact wats lejano well so
well known before neva that revolution
came up might he had all the elements to
become a good leader the question now is
is there any venezuelan vaclav havel
maybe somebody we don't know that could
emerge as a charismatic leader able to
change everything
the answer is unfortunately that we
don't know and this is why we should
talk about a more pessimistic scenario
[Music]
romanian way out what happens when a
dictator doesn't want to leave power
even if the situation is getting out of
hand
I'm telling you right now it's nothing
good we've said it before here a visual
politic despite how it looks being an
authoritarian ruler is a risky job
Callaspo chess school is the best proof
of this we are talking about one of the
most brutal dictators we ever had in
Europe
[Music]
unlike nicolas maduro nicolas Ceausescu
didn't even care about pretending to
organize elections it was a system based
on the cult of personality but you know
when the economy goes south even
Europe's most authoritarian dictator has
problems just like the rest of the
communist countries at the end of the
1980s Romania was at the edge of
bankruptcy in some regions they even had
kids with malnutrition nonetheless on
December 25th 1989 after giving a
massive speech the citizens went from
clapping their hands to booing him in a
matter of seconds days later the
Romanian equivalent of Kim jong-un was
executed by his people
[Applause]
we are not talking about a revolution
against the regime he was not even
killed Mike antagonistic activists in
fact Ceausescu was executed by the
members of his own party it was kind of
entering coup d'etat a moderate faction
of the Romanian Communist Party to the
control of the Romanian government in
the case of Venezuela this could be a
faction of his own government or Theon
II of course it doesn't have to finish
with the execution of anybody they could
just kick him out of the country and he
could end up living in a mansion in any
other nation that would accept him it
wouldn't be the first time this has
happened and it certainly won't be the
last but just like in Romania the
changes in government would be pure lip
service different phases but the same
values the same policies although
perhaps a little more moderate well it
is clear in today's Romania is not a
special example of a transition but at
least now we have a stable country with
some economic movement and growth and
without extreme poverty anymore and
there are opportunities in the for the
future for people living there
[Music]
and I do now have to make a serious and
important assignment I want to be really
clear about this we're not wishing any
personal harm on nicolas maduro or
anyone from his government here a visual
politic we would never advocate for any
kind of violence in this video we're
simply exploring potential scenarios
that might or might not happen based on
previous occurrences and that really is
all that said this Romanian way out
doesn't seem likely to happen either
that is why we will focus on the latest
possible scenario something that might
sound surreal but everything seems to be
possible in Venezuela
a country for sale that Chinese way out
in this other video we explained to you
why China is the only strong ally left
of Venezuela truth is that China has
lent more than sixty billion dollars to
Madhuri's governments much of this
credit comes in what we call oil loans
this means China gives money to
Venezuela and Venezuela instead of
giving back hard currency it gives oil
barrels and this makes sense right if
there is something abundant in this
country that would certainly be its
dinosaur juice in fact they have the
world's biggest reserves so it seems to
be a pretty good deal for Maduro
right
[Music]
well there is a problem here because as
you know the Venezuelan oil company
pdvsa has a big crisis - it is more
expensive to drill and extract oil in
Venezuela than in any other country
including Norway and Canada
this explains why PDVSA can no longer
extract their own resources this company
is producing at just 43 percent of their
capacity and it's getting lower and
lower or many Chinese investors are
losing their patience don't forget we
are not only talking about sitting in
government here there are many private
companies involved here companies the
birth of an Israeli in debt bonds or
firms that had a stake on an Australian
industry this is why we can find news
like this
[Music]
China's Sinopec zoos Venezuela in sign
of fraying relations so the question now
on the real question is what would
happen in Venezuela if they can't give
back those Chinese loans well a default
is unlikely China is paying for the
military and the police over Maduro this
means that at any moment they could
simply shut down the government
so what could they do instead well they
could seize PDVSA properties and these
my dear viewers are the crown jewels of
this country
[Music]
the brand-new pdvsa or by the way the
board of managers could do the necessary
reforms so the company can go back to
work normally look today PDVSA assets
are worth two hundred and thirty billion
dollars but Madero owes Xi Jingping
more than sixty billion dollars in other
words Beijing could be entitled to seize
1/4 of pdvsa s assets and don't forget
that PDVSA is the biggest if not the
only company in Venezuela
don't forget is that their dinosaur
juice is 97 percent of their exports
so only PDVSA is sort of the same as
owning Venezuela as a whole well in
principle this would be good for good
news for Venezuelan economy but it would
immobilize Nicolas maduro's government
in other words it would be like selling
the whole country which the Chinese
investors
okay all right so I know what you're all
thinking
right now you're probably thinking come
on Simon this is science fiction it
can't actually happen well let me tell
you that there are already signs that
something like this could happen just
look at the news published in Xinhua
news as you probably guessed by the name
Xinhua news is a Chinese news site that
follows Xi Jinping's views have a look
at this
[Music]
Maduro creates Venezuela's first petrol
special economic zone any time China
wants to do big business with a poorer
country the first thing they do is
create a special economic zone an area
with special laws based on Chinese
regulations and no taxes for business
but in this case this could even go
further we're not talking about
investing in a country or doing business
we are talking about buying the backbone
of the Bolivarian revolution here
without PDVSA Maduro is like a hip-hop
artist without the bling-bling chains so
if you can control the economy of a
country including the way that it gets
its finances couldn't we say that you've
sort of already bought it well this is
what could end up happening in Venezuela
it will be one of the first times in
history where a whole nation is sold to
another
again this is really hard to conceive
but as I've already said everything is
possible in Venezuela but now well it's
your turn
which of these three scenarios is more
likely to happen or do you think we'll
see a mixture of all of them these won't
leave your answer in the comments
section below it has been a pleasure to
be here with you guys if you want to
keep in touch with me you can find me on
Twitter at Devon bar see you soon maybe
also please don't forget to check out
our patreon page so you can support this
project and if you liked this video
please do subscribe to this channel so
you won't miss any posts and as always
I'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and here
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media we have a
podcast at reconsidered Mediacom slash
podcast see you there
[Music]
you